oh excuse me excuse me sir you were late
for pickup oh I'm sorry there was no
parking spots daddy Nate hey little
buddy what's up I missed you man me too
you were late for pickup yeah I told you
I couldn't find a spot I'm sorry we
don't accept excuses wasn't an excuse
just what happened plus I was only like
2 minutes late right buddy have you read
the school guide book it's a dollar for
every minute you're late just oh no the
first violation is free really well then
why didn't you tell me that before I put
my kid down well if you'd actually read
the guide book instead of just saying
you did I wouldn't have to tell you
anything is it like a problem him miss
you have some sort of issue with me what
you do is you take me aside in private
and you talk to me you don't dress me
down in front of my kid I'm paying you
to educate my son not me okay well we
here at little hearts and Minds believe
that education extends into the home
once again fantastic you know that
actually picked up the guide book and
started Jesus Christ I read the goddamn
[__] guide book all right you Stumpy
little cun